welcome to this video fernanda motta
mondometer okay I'm black and this guy
is playing the Smith Maura yeah okay I'm
chickening out I really don't don't feel
so confident in the index epted let's
just play play this type of position
that's my Roxy bind type of position I
often feel that players who play the
Smith Maura I'm not that well versed in
this here you should play age three for
example okay I should chief I ever
that's a weird move what is he doing can
I know they can even I can even try to
use this or try to make use of that
immediately like take here yeah this is
after Bishop g7 I mean mmm and 92 maybe
then I have 95 which at least gives me
the bishops
now it should be okay
you
okay I was thinking of taking on c3
anyway so I'm going to do that keyless
structure so 95 now intending
threatening to win the peace so he has
to move the bishop probably one of the
bishops now I have this coming directly
attacking see form maybe you can play f4
hmm you can maybe platform now I takes
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen deform
and my rook is hanging maybe yeah but ok
i'm at least Im I'm ahead on the clock
for once mhm I so I cannot take it's not
good tags theoretically speaking I can
play f6 at the end of this line but it
looks really really weird
okay maybe I can still use this somehow
with so that i can play Knight f6 here
now I was a stupid lamp there should be
six I should have thought about that a
moment it's a even the same thing with
f6 and so did this is the difference
that can go to f7 maybe or with h6
inserted it's also a bit different okay
maybe there's nothing really bad
happening but it's it's really something
that is so far too late yeah what should
he do now maybe look be one or something
like that trying to attack on b7 but I
have night f6f Knight f6 is now that he
has played f4e for is this really
weakened okay so Knight f6 maybe just
try to attack the weak spot come on
let's try to keep this this clock
advantage for once
that looks that looks okay actually
don't see why I should have any of any
substantial trouble yeah how is he
covering if I anyway Bishop d3 maybe but
I have 95 Quinn to deform it's not the
most natural-looking move ever but yeah
it is there I just played hmm yeah maybe
maybe come on let's let's try to get the
Queen's of this of this
okay I thought I can take and play night
age five actually maybe I am wrong the
avid ok let's take first him and now
night h5 attending night g3 to f5 am i
overlooking something here
yeah I don't know there's a kind of
position okay if I'm not like mated or
I'm overlooking something very very
drastic then I'm just strategically
almost winning him because he has his
position basically consists of
weaknesses I can just jump in here right
it's no reason not to I can take each YJ
it takes you form
maybe you should think of 96 but 96 is a
double check Bishop hangs Andrew gangs
now that looks white looks past the gym
yes the move now
yeah I think I'll just take this come on
just keep it simple yeah 96 is attacking
the bishop it didn't matter really this
was a loss White has far too many
weaknesses
ok it's a piece
white resigns yeah i mean i really did a
made a very stupid mistake with it with
bishop e6 but yeah i'm not sure about
this whole Bishop g5 business it's
probably not a really bad mood but
normally what white is doing is
displaying something like that age three
to make sure that I get not Bishop g4
into trade the bishop and then we get
this typical maroc see style play where
why this always a little bit better yeah
I thought maybe night GE to war Uxie one
could be an option but he went 83 which
is not really clear to me that the
purpose of the move ok so I'm going to
do this now threatening 93 and Queen g5
so yeah he went here and now this was
you but yeah getting this in so quickly
I should just think for a moment and
then decide on a good move here here for
example here h6 is much stronger yeah
now he has a head you know he has a
problem if he goes straight for I get in
this with it I'm sorry wrong this is
this one I'm attacking me for very
effectively yeah I black is an excellent
you know I mean age 3 is just a yes to
play f3 which makes h3 like totally
ridiculous so here probably and then I
have this business yeah this is
fantastic for black yeah h6 was the way
to punish wide for is we had opening
play with age 3 Bishop g5 and all this
stuff and this is just running into this
stupid okay i went back here clean
deform yeah not sure about Quincy five
but I wanted to have yeah some
simplicity him after I had overlooked
things
the computer gives Knight d2 here with a
pretty good position for wine I
interesting maybe it wants to play
Knight b3 out there at the right moment
that's not a bad move anyway it covers
you for c4 and so on yeah why tis ok
yeah I mean now I suspected that much
but this this I'm not sure about what
about this I took recaptured and nine
age five yeah at least I have a clear
idea I want to jump to g3 and if I get
there I'm in excellent shape there are a
couple yeah engine suggests king of to
know that mmhmm yeah the computer
sometimes makes really logical moves
covering this weakness then I g7 maybe
in 10 8 95 it gives us as about equal
but there it's equal maybe but it's not
like boring it's a very unbalanced the
situation and here I'm probably just
winning now right dr minus 1.5 yeah I
get to g3 simply and there's 94 in the
mix and rook c8 see for his weak white
is just full of weaknesses yeah so here
he is losing the a bit of a weird game
and yeah and I'm bit i'm a bit annoyed
that i played bishop is 6 you know so
quickly my typical thing that I
criticize people for playing too quickly
this happened to me here I played this
in six seconds which is stupid because
it's clear that there's already
something wrong with whites position
like Age 3 didn't make much sense this
Bishop d3 and back and he's got this
rotten pawn structure so I should really
think from normal and try to use this to
the fullest okay it didn't it wasn't
punished him thanks for watching